Speaker 1: This weekend, Donald Trump is going
to be speaking at a rally in Arizona.
I will be covering that rally.
One of the people that is reportedly speaking
alongside Donald Trump at that rally is none
other than MyPillow founder Mike Lindell,
known to us as Mike Pillow.
Lindell says he's going to be one of the opening
acts at Donald Trump's January 15th rally
in Arizona and expect 60000 people to show
up.
Why do I mention that?
Well, someone who is going to be appearing
alongside the former president of the United
States is now claiming that he has evidence
to imprison 300 million Americans for their
actions related to the 2020 election.
Now, you might say, Wait, David, sir.
There are only two hundred and fifty eight
million adults in the U.S. as of 2020, and
of the two hundred and fifty eight million,
not all of them, not nearly all of them actually
voted.
Doesn't matter.
Pillow says he has evidence to imprison 300
some million people.
Take a listen to what he had to say.
This is the stuff of insanity.
Speaker 2: Everything you're going to see
over these next seven months, right?
Get rid of the machines.
You're going to see a Supreme Court case coming
out.
All these great things.
Everybody, by the way, you can find more refreshing
speech dot com.
Of course, I'll put that little out.
Put that out there.
There are so many.
I'm more optimistic today than I have been
yesterday the day before, and I'm on an incline
like this.
Why?
Because it's so amazing all the things that
we have.
We already have all the piece of the puzzle
and you talking about evidence.
We had enough evidence to put everybody in
prison for life.
Three hundred and some million people, we
are there all the way back to November, December.
Speaker 1: He has the evidence to put three
hundred and some million people in prison
for life.
Now, before we get back to that, if you're
wondering about that scratchy, weird voice
that he has, I will mention that our friend,
Zachary Patrizio from The Daily Beast reported
about that yesterday and says MyPillow CEO
Mike Lindell has come down with a severe case
of quote laryngitis.
And he added in a comment to The Daily Beast,
I can't get COVID while citing his consumption
of an unproven COVID 19 drug.
He probably has COVID is my understanding
of that.
But more importantly, evidence to imprison
300 something million Americans for life.
So if there's only two hundred and fifty eight
million adults as of 2020.
He's talking about imprisoning every adult
who voted, every adult who didn't vote and
then 42 million children, so things going
very, very wrong for Mike Lindell in all,
all senses of the word likely has COVID and
again claims he will be speaking at the Trump
rally this week.
And now I will be covering the Trump rally,
and many of you have written in saying, David,
please cover the Trump rally.
Others have said, David, don't cover the Trump
rally.
I'm going to cover the Trump rally.
It is fascinating.
You know, I just cover what is interesting
and I am fascinated to see.
Does the topic of vaccines come up at the
rally and does Trump get booed?
Trump has been pushing the vaccines pretty
hard, saying, of course everybody needs freedom,
but pretty significantly pushing the vaccines.
Is he going to get booed in Arizona for promoting
the vaccines?
Is Trump going to make an announcement about
2024?
Is Trump going to make any announcements about
support for candidates in 2022?
Is Mike Lindell really allowed to go and speak
alongside the former president, given that
he almost certainly has COVID right now and
also is completely out of his mind?
And it's humiliating that he's even allowed
near the president?
I mean, it's all completely crazy, so I will
be covering the rally.
If it's not interesting to you, just don't
watch it.
That that's my recommendation, but I will
be live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook, starting
at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Saturday.
Trump expected to speak at 9:00 p.m., meaning
he will likely speak between 10:00 p.m. and
midnight.
I don't know.
He's always historically, he's always insanely
late to his speaking engagements, so that's
going to be this weekend.
In the meantime, we have no idea what sort
of evidence Mike Pillow claims to have, but
I would guess that you and I would not find
it particularly compelling.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
David Pakman.
Remember that we are still banned from Facebook
monetization.
We're like five days into our 90 day ban for
what Facebook's algorithm misidentified as
anti-vaccine content from us.
Laughable claim.
You all know that we are pro vaccine because
that's what the science points to, and we
were reporting on anti-vax Alex Jones, and
we have been banned from Facebook monetization
for 90 days.
You can support us in that in fighting that
endeavor by signing up at Join Pacman dot
com and using the coupon code EFF.
Facebook that's Facebook with two F's EFF
Facebook.
You tell me what it means, so we'll take a
break.
We have a fantastic program
for
you today.
Glad you're with us!
Welcome back to the show.
Remember that we are primarily funded by viewers
and listeners like you through the David Pakman
Show membership program.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.